Your people need a leader
You'll need resources to fight this war
that Ritson has launched on your people
And I can give them to you
I will use you, you will use me
and together will make this planet safe
for both our people
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
The Secret Invasion Episode
6 finale had a big Excalibur in Captain
Britain teaser
at the end of the episode,
confirming Marvel has plans to do
the actual team at some point.
Those characters
with Emilia Clarke and Olivia Colman,
including Kit Harington's, Black Knight
and a bunch of other characters
they're doing on upcoming series
in upcoming movies.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
A soldier episodes are starting
in a couple of weeks
and then we'll get Loki Season
two episodes.
I'll be doing videos for everything it,
it felt like secret invasion in
general was kind of lackluster
compared to comic books.
Secret invasion.
Asoka Loki will probably be
some of the best Disney
Plus series that they've ever done so far.
but careful for spoilers
from Secret Invasion
if you haven't seen the episodes yet.
at the end of the episode though,
Emilia Clarke guy character kills graphic
with her new Super Skrull powers
having gained the ability to mimic
pretty much most of the MCU characters.
Everyone who was at the final Battle
of Avengers Endgame,
including some of the crazy
powerful ones like Thanos, Scarlet Witch,
Captain Marvel, Thor.
In fact, it's easier to say
which powers she doesn't have
now because vision, for example,
was still dead.
And he doesn't have DNA to begin with.
He's an android, so he's like the only
character whose powers she didn't get.
she almost becomes
the new, most powerful MCU character ever.
There's a couple of characters
that are more powerful than her,
but in the comics, the Skrulls who could
mimic powers like this during the comic
book Secret Invasion were limited to using
just four powers at any given time.
that was the way they balanced them out
to keep them from getting too poppy.
And when they were using those powers,
they weren't as powerful
as the original person
that they were copying.
And I think that's how
they're going to balance.
Emilia Clarke's character now
say that she's not as powerful
as the original versions, just a fraction,
the amount.
instead of going with Nick Fury
to his saber space station,
they have a teaser for Sonya Bosworth,
pulling her own British version
of the Nick Fury Iron Man
Post-Credits scene showing up to recruit
Emilia Clarke
to a version of Excalibur in the MCU.
You. Are you a friend of a friend?
she also tells her to become
the new Skrull empress,
like the new Skrull Khaleesi,
to make more Game of Thrones references.
We have so many Game of Thrones
actors joining the MCU now, don't worry,
I'll get to Kit Harington's
Black Knight, too,
because he's another British character
with ties
to a lot of the Excalibur characters
as well.
During the scene,
they even play a little Captain Britain
theme music lingering on the moment
just a little.
So it's obvious that they do intend on
paying this team off or putting together
a new squad
and in the MCU.
They'll basically just use this
as the British version of The Avengers.
So it'll be a little bit different
from the comics, but pretty close
some of the roster.
We'll have to be a little bit different,
especially at first
just because there's a lot of characters
that they haven't gotten
even close to introducing yet,
particularly the X-Men based characters.
Captain Britain
would be like the biggest next character
that they would have to introduce,
but they've already kind of done that.
They already teased him in the MCU
Kit Harington's Black Knight character
wasn't on that original comic book team
either, but he is a British character
and shares a lot of the same characters
as this caliber.
So he's a bit of a crossover character,
mostly in Merlin.
Morgan Levey The Black Knights origins
go back to Camelot, Knights of the Round
Table, The King Arthur Chronicles,
which is a big crossover point
for the Excalibur team.
they even introduced the Excalibur sword
during the Eternals movie, including Kit
Harington's,
Black Knight, the Ebony Blade.
They explained
the Eternals lived in actual Camelot
for a brief period in the UK
during that part of history, revealing
that Camelot was a real place in the MCU.
Merlin, who created the Ebony
Blade, was a real person.
He was probably the sorcerer
supreme of his era.
some of that starts to get into multiverse
territory, too,
like Merlin, becomes
more of a multiverse character,
like a multiverse version of Doctor
Strange.
Morgan, let's say, for
example, was a real sorceress
who, in present day is actually supposed
to be played by Aubrey Plaza
during the Agatha Coven of Chaos episodes.
She's a huge Excalibur villain.
the earlier teaser for Captain
Britain went back to Avengers Endgame.
I talked about this when the movie
came out a couple of years ago.
You probably remember,
which was them basically saying
that they were doing the character
at some point
when Captain America
goes back to the 1970s with Iron Man
during the time heist, he's inside
Peggy Carter's office.
And here's her mention.
Agent Braddock is out on a mission
now this
is meant to be the 1970s, remember?
So I'm assuming that it'd be Brian
Braddock's either parents or his ancestor
at some point
because Brian Braddock is a multiverse
character,
he does jump around time and space.
It could have also been a version
of Brian Braddock in this scene.
But that's meant to be his real name.
He is Brian Braddock.
He's kind of like the British version
of Captain America,
even though his origin story
and his powers are completely different.
This is the way the people view him.
Like, if you're not a big comic book,
then you see him,
you see, Oh, it's kind of like British
Captain America In reality, he's
completely different from Captain America,
for those who either want to see
Henry Cavill show up in the MCU.
That actually be a pretty solid pick
for him
because, for instance, he's
not going to play the century.
The century is kind of like Marvel's
version of a more sinister bent Superman,
like a crazy version of Superman
they're supposed to already be using.
Steven Yeun is a version of that character
in the Thunderbolts movie.
We'll meet MCU Sentry during
Thunderbolts, though.
Captain Britain's origin story
starts with him as just a normal kid born
in the UK to an aristocratic family
that had fallen on hard times
and lost their fortune as a child,
he studied science.
His sister
is actually psylocke of the X-Men.
So that's why Excalibur is a big X-Men
based team his parents were killed
in a mysterious, quote unquote
mysterious lab accident under foul play.
He starts studying at the dark War
Nuclear Research Center.
Later in life gets attacked by the river.
in as he's escaping it crashes
his motorcycle and is visited by Merlin
and his daughter Roma,
who offer him a chance
to become captain Britain
offering to heal him
and prevent him from dying.
If he agrees they give him the choice of
the amulet of right or the sword of might.
He rejects the sword
and chooses the amulet,
and it gives him
the powers of Captain Britain healing him.
He becomes part of the Captain Britain
Corps, a multiversal team run by Merlin's
daughter, who are like a more righteous
version of the TVA, protecting reality
across the multiverse
from different threads.
Then we get to the formation
of the Excalibur team.
So this actually formed
in the wake of an X-Men based event called
Fall of the X-Men, where Captain Britain,
Kitty Pryde, Nightcrawler Shadow
cast in McGann, who was Captain Britain's
girlfriend at the time, being together
to save Rachel Summers,
daughter of Cyclops in Jean Gray.
once they successfully save her,
they decide to carry
on the legacy of the X-Men
by forming Excalibur.
very apropos.
They're introducing the Rachel
Summers character during the new X-Men,
the Animated Series season
at the beginning of next year, X-Men
97, Season one, basically
they released a teaser at Comic-Con
that they didn't post online.
And in the clip, Jean Gray was pregnant
with Rachel Summers.
when Excalibur bands together,
they use the Excalibur sword
to create a secret base for themselves
called the Lighthouse that Merlin
could also control eventually wind up
destroying that base so that they could
free themselves from Merlin's control.
Because in that scenario,
he was kind of like a version of Nick Fury
for the Avengers team
having more influence over them.
obviously the MCU version of the team
would be very different, much closer
to a British version of The Avengers.
The way they're pitching it
during the end of Secret Invasion here,
like Sonia Bosworth
would be their version of Nick Fury
and they'd be more of an Earth based team,
maybe with some multiversal stuff,
but not quite as crazy as the comic book
version.
The team,
But we are in the middle
of this multiverse saga
like we're heading to Avengers
six secret wars.
What they might do, though,
because there's a lot of characters
that are on this team
that haven't been introduced yet,
particularly X-Men characters.
They might wait till after Secret Wars
to actually do the team.
they haven't said when they plan on
doing a legit version of Captain Brendon
or introducing an actor
to actually play the character,
for example, like Henry
Cavill would be a solid pick for that.
there's been a lot of talk
about Marvel using secret wars
to do a soft reboot of the MCU in general.
I don't think
they'll do a complete reboot,
but they might return a couple of things.
And in the whole idea
that Marvel phase four
or five and six
have been the multiverse saga,
they're culminating in Avengers
Secret Wars.
I think Marvel Phase seven
will begin the Mutant Saga, for example,
like a very X-Men themed type of saga.
we'll start to see Easter eggs
and references
to that during Deadpool three
when they bring back
all the classic X-Men actors and sort of
like a swan song to their characters.
some of them will be back in Avengers
Secret wars
and even before they do the legit version
of the Excalibur team together.
Emilia Clarke, Kit Harington's
Black Knight will be back in cameos
during Marvel Phase six at some point.
this also be the way to do a big reunion
between those two characters.
On Sweet like more Game of Thrones
actors in the MCU.
they did a small version of that
during the Eternals movie.
When you have Richard Madden having
a reunion with Kit Harington on screen,
the whole joke about that
is that when they saw each other again,
he'd become the Black Knight.
It was just in a completely different
cinematic universe.
one of the reasons why
I think they're also waiting
on doing a ton of Black Knight
related stuff is because Kit Harington
has that Jon Snow Game of Thrones sequel
that he's trying to develop.
It sounds like that's more of a priority
to him than doing a bunch of Marvel stuff
right now.
He was supposed to show up in the Blade
movie again,
but they've completely changed
what that movie is going to be.
So he's not going to be
in the new version of The Blade movie.
Let me know in the comments
they do version of Excalibur in the MCU.
Who do you want to be
on that original team
or do you just want them to wait
until after Avengers Secret Wars
so they can do a more legit version
of the comic book original team
with a bunch of those X-Men characters
there's a bunch of stuff
that I'm working on and a bunch of stuff
that'll be happening in the next week.
I'll try to do videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here for my full secret invasion
Episode 6 finale video and click here
for all my Comic-Con trailers.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!